good evening the las vegas raiders are
the first nfl team in the country to
require proof of vaccination for fans to
attend a home game thanks for joining us
i'm denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
that major decision coming on the heels
of a big announcement for all large
venues in nevada orco man is live right
now at legion stadium tonight to break
it all down orco
well brian and denise raider fans coming
to watch games here at allegion stadium
must show proof of vaccination and those
who are fully vaccinated will be
required will not be required to wear
masks and on the other end of the
spectrum those not vaccinated will
are not allowed to attend and this is
all in line with a new statewide
directive
this is cutting edge there's no other
venues in the country that are doing
this a significant step in the fight
against covet 19 governor steve sisilak
announcing a new option for large venues
in nevada when it comes to the indoor
mask mandate if a large event venue
chooses to require vaccination proof for
all attendees
those that are fully vaccinated will be
allowed to take their masks off those
who are not vaccinated cannot attend
those who have gotten one dose can
attend but they are required to wear
masks and children not yet eligible for
vaccination can also attend but they
must wear masks governor sislek making
it clear this is a choice for venues
that seat 4 thousand people or more this
isn't a mandate it's not a requirement
the las vegas raiders will do this at
allegiant stadiums starting september
13th some fully vaccinated visitors like
the idea of not wearing masks i want to
see faces you know what i'm saying you
know all you've seen is eyes you know
you don't see who's who or what's what
others say they want everyone to wear
masks regardless of vaccination status
they're concerned with enforcement of
the new option i still think it's just
going to push the
you know fake vaccination for the people
that don't want to be vaccinated but
governor sisilak says venues will have
strict policies in place event operators
must implement a method of verifying
vaccination status that is accurate
effective and reliable
the governor says one goal of this is to
encourage more people to get vaccinated
state health officials will work with
event operators to have pop-up vaccine
sites at large venues and if you get
your shot and then you're allowed to go
inside the venue with the mask on and
the raiders have already announced this
is something that they're doing before
home games reporting live at allegion
stadium orca mana 8 news now
the state board of health will meet
later this week to talk about vaccine
requirements for college students in our
state tonight the nevada system of
higher education sharing a statement
saying the goal is to quote ensure a
safe collegiate environment for our
students faculty staff and the community
whether in a classroom or an athletic
event end quote